>>> IN OUR 2, THE D
IS GROWI IN THE 2024 PRESIDENTI
C SIDE, L MB AT 12  T THI-PATE E
DRCOL WESTWHO LAUCHED
HI
PEOPLE'S P DR. WEST
JOINUSSTT ME W
OBVIS  YOU
E R SUHAT YOU
THINK JODE NOUGHENTION TO TO TO?
>> WELL, I MEA, MY DEAR BROTHEH
CALLING TO WIN. AT THE GHEST LE.
M TRYING TE
FINISH LINE, WCAO REINTRES ITS
OTD NGSTER NOT THEBROTHER BIDELA
I WANT TO DOF JOSEPH ACE BALD
THE IMPOVERIND POOANG PEARTIES L
MILITARISM, PENTAGON, ED T
WHAT ABOUT OPPRESSES
AMERICOLORS WHO AR M FOOD ON THE
HAT WH IS
TIED TO THEIR Q>>
TURIOUS
ICAN DEMOCRACYOT J, BUT THE WHO
.
EINGALBROTHER  WITH FOSSIL FUELS
MANCHIN IN TF PIPELINEILL DO IN
VEINE EAST CSTA DEAL WITS
GO OFFER THE FILIBUSTEHER BIDE
WEING BETTER.
>> NOT JUST THY?
HERE BUTTHD
ABROA
I'M DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT, B IN LATIN
AFRICAMIDDLE
EAST.
>> I HEAR YO THESE TIONS OFTEDO
A BINARY C
DEMOCRAT AND THE REPUBLICAN.
DR. LA TRIBERVARSSOR
TWEETEWTF.U TANDS FOR.
DOES CORNE RLLHELP T WH NADELP
GORE I
EA FEA
THINGS THAT YOCAHELP,
SL
SAP AWAY ENOUGH TE
PROGRESSIVES WTHVOTE FOR SWRIDEU
RENCE VIEWREPUBN S AN
URE.
>> O, BROTHER
TR THEN THROUGTHEWS.
EITHS OR T
FRICK ORLE
E DISASTERS SASTERS?ABSO
A THAT BROTHER TRUMP D REDUCE -B
DO AND FOCUSN THIS ABLE SUFFERI
WORLD AS SOME EGO, SAY
ALMIGHTY, WHAT ARE YOU
DOING, DO YO  RICH LEGACYHA
D IN THE ELECT CONTEXT OF THE P'
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE EITHER TH HA
IOUS DSSMASSRATION OF 'S BEEN G
WORLD,Y BASEAROUNDTH
HEGEE K R OPPRESSED
PALESTINIAOTND
ERWHAT THE BOMBS
TH IAND IRITUAY TRNEOLIBERALO VW
THE WORLD ERER
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATSR , WE E
FASCISM, WHICH IS ON E
MARCY MIAST IBERAL
Y
THAT'S WHY I'M GP M.ET
COUNLK TO SOME OF MY W
OT
E  PIED
PEM YOUR
LOOK ANOTH
WO MARTIKING.
LET US EMBRACE ONE A
ACCEG BESTATG
E WHO RIGH
WT NT.
CLIFTON WEST CALLS A PARADIG
SHIFT IN AMERICAN POLITICS.
PRACTI IN PART WHAT THIS IS Y B
WHERE DO THE PEOPLS PARTY,
WHERE WIE ON THE BALLOT?AL
MICHIGAN?
WILL YOU BE ON THE BALLOT IN
SCOPLE'SARTY
WAS ON THEIN
STATES LAST TIME.
ARE YOU HOPING TO GET ON THEBAL
MAKE SURE WE ON OKE M IEISE  INN
ATTEMPT IN 2016. WE'RE VERY AT
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT  CITIZEN
HE BESME
ABOUT.ERICA,T OF
ANY NATION IS ABPOOR AND WORKIN
SEXU, AND NO
CONFG THI'
WITH IRANIANS DEALIN
FAELITES.
I'ING ABOUT SOLIDARITYDARITYWIO.
WITH WRS IGUATEMALA.IS  MY BROT.
HE
WAS NC
BOMBS DROPPED INAL
HAS TURNEDPOOR WHITE HAVE GOT AS
TOO OFTEN TO TH
HEABLE.
'S M
BROTR.DR. WEST, I HAVE A TON
MORE QUESTIONS BUT WE'RE OUT OF
CLOCKCOME
AND WE'RE INIC
AND YOUR PLATFORMS NEX  H